[Musik]
bis bald gast ist die blm unique
heutigen sitzung ist zweierlei erstens
die ästhetik und zweitens fußball
sie brauchen nicht dass ich sage dass
fußball manchmal enttäuschend ist und
sogar ungerecht ich werde nicht auf die
auf gestern an den ich wollte aber was
also einem anderen fußball ereignis aus
der näheren vergangenheit sagen nämlich
das endspiel der champions league
wer hat das gesehen dieses spiel okay
für die das nicht gesehen haben
das war das war mehr oder weniger wie
herr der ringe
es gab kleine gerechte gute leute und
sehr starke macht mächtige böse leute
mit dem unterschied dass im fußball die
ungerechten bösen gewonnen haben
und vor allem geht es mir darum nicht
nur nichts im nichts weil dies die
sieger im allgemeinen zu beschränken
sondern
[Applaus]
diese person also gibt es gibt
verschiedene boshafte menschen der welt
sie sehr viel einfluss haben zum
beispiel der macht für von nordkorea
donald trump aber am schlimmsten ist
diese person sergio ramos also kurze
zusammenfassung nicht seiner karriere
übrigens ich bin kein rebell pro verein
ich bin oslos werden war aber für läufer
pro in dieser firma in diesem fall kurze
zusammenfassung nicht seiner ganzen
karriere und alle sachen die er
veranstaltet hat während dieser kerl
weil dafür würden wir die ganzen 90
minuten brauchen aber in diesem endspiel
hat er erstens den schulter sind das
beste spiel von webos wirkliche
ausgerissen war bei einem zweikampf dann
heimlich mit seinen ellbogen den torwart
von der po getroffen danach
es wird vermutet dass der torwart einen
gehirnerschütterung geleitet hat und
danach hat der torwart zwei sehr krasse
fehler gemacht und dadurch hatten wir
das spiel verloren
ramos würde nicht einmal eine gelbe
karte dafür bekommen hat keine strafe
bekommt dafür bekommen seien manche
seine mannschaft hat an die champions
league gewonnen zum nächsten mal
und er wird wahrscheinlich jetzt die wm
auch gewinnen dürfen weil spanien in der
schwächeren hälfte des turniers ist okay
also das führt zu mehr die frage
natürlich mehrere für das sorbische
fragen erstens kann man nur anhand
sergio ramos beweisen dass gott nicht
existiert
im allgemeinen heißt das niveau also das
problem des bösen man kann sagen dass
gott nicht existiert weil ein guter
allmächtiger gott ungerechtigkeit und
böse in der welt nichts nichts erlauben
würde also ganz konkret könnte könnte
man sagen würde ein guter allmächtiger
gott erlauben dass sergio ramos
existiert antwort nein gott existiert
nicht
aber dieses problem wollte ich nicht
besprechen ich wollte was soziales
beschreiten und vielleicht etwas
interessanteres und das geht das ist mir
eingefahren als ich gesehen habe dass
viele leute die frage gestellt haben ob
ramos absichtlich mohammed salat diesen
posten spieler noch einmal soll es
übrigens wahrscheinlich der beliebteste
fußballspieler der welt zurzeit vor
allem in der islamischen welt dass er
wirklich ein held als auch ägypten ist
praktizierende muslimin und die ganze
welt wollten sehen wie salat in diesem
spiel dann dass er erfolgreich und nach
von sie mögen oder so hat man es eben
sein schulter so ausgeklügelt und da war
es da würde es kommt übrigens bald so
alles okay ist da würde es sehr viel
diskutiert danach ob das absicht war
oder nicht weil es geht alles natürlich
sehr schnell und in zeitlupe hat dass er
absichtlich aus man könnte sagen also
ist das wirklich glaubwürdig dass ramos
auf dass das spielplatz geht mit der
absicht den besten spieler so zu
verletzen dass er nicht mehr
weiterspielen kann oder lauert die ganze
erwartet auf eine gelegenheit das zu tun
weil das würde wirklich wirklich schlimm
also meine vermutung wahrscheinlich
schon aber nehmen wir an das ist nicht
der fall
der punkt den ich machen will ist ein
sehr ästhetischen punkt nämlich das
laster und böse
normalerweise nicht so funktioniert
normalerweise funktioniert laster so
dass man sozusagen intuitiv oder oder
spontan auf eine situation reagiert
in einer art und weise die böse ist oder
richtige für alle hieß ist die tugend
auch so dass man nicht sozusagen im
voraus schon einen plan hat wie man
vorgehen wird vielleicht manchmal schon
aber typischerweise funktioniert die
tuben so ich bin einen in einer
situation und ich wähle den richtigen
weg weil diese richtige wahl für mich
irgendwie natürlich fällt oder spontan
offensichtlich ist oder wie wir sehen
werden ich genieße die tugendhafte
handlung und verachte die last
lasterhafte gibt es das lasterhafte dass
die ich verachte die lasterhafte
handlung einfach wegen meines charakters
und wenn man einen lasterhafte charakter
hat ist man genau in der gegenteiligen
situation also meine vermutung ist
sergio ramos ist jemand der durch eine
erziehung durch durch erfolg über viele
jahren wenn er so spielt hat er
irgendwie gelernt dass es gut ist
sozusagen in jeder situation zu
reagieren dass man vielleicht die den
gegner verletzt so lang man nicht dafür
nicht bestraft wird und er muss nichts
zu sagen bewusst überlegen oder
kalkulieren dass er das macht herrn
macht's einfach und so das ist richtig
vielleicht sogar in diesem fall ist
richtig aber ernsthafter ist ist die
bemerkung dass ethische handlung sehr
oft in dieser weise vorgeht und das auto
ist das entdeckt hat man kann das auch
sehr gut mit zum beispiel mit damit
vergleichen das was wir bei platon und
partys bei plattform gesehen haben
nämlich diese idee dass die tugend aus
wissen besteht also tun ist
eine art wissen vielleicht wissen über
ethische fragen oder ist das begreifen
von ethischen begriffen zb tapferkeit
oder gerechtigkeit und wenn man in der
lage ist zu sagen was die gerechtigkeit
ist dann hat man die tugend der
gerechtigkeit und kann und
dementsprechend handeln
das ist nicht alles die ist analyse der
ethik seine erlöse der ethik ist eher
dass die tugend ein zustand der zähne
ist vielleicht oder ein also eine
charaktereigenschaft vielleicht ein sehr
guter ausdruck dafür und anhand dieser
charaktereigenschaft handelt man
entweder lasterhafte tugendhaft oder in
der mitte ok also unser ziel für heute
ist zu entdecken wie alles wirklich ist
das begründet und was und warum diese
einzig so wichtig für seine ethik ist
ich bin das lustig dass sergio ramos das
einziger ist das aus der tafel steht
übrigens ich wollte was des kurses über
die klausur sagen also der plan ab heute
ist heute tätig erste sitzung celtic
nächste woche zweite sitzung zu ethik
und in zwei wochen gibt es eine sitzung
wo ich will nur eine lediglich für eine
halbe stunde voll lesen werde und ich
werde in dieser in diesen 30 minuten die
ganze restliche geschichte der antiken
philosophie besprechen also ein sprint
der antike philosophie nach alles orte
ließ dann gibt es eine 60-minütige
klausur diejenige die die klausel nicht
schreiben können natürlich gehen und die
klausur wird so aufgebaut sein dass wir
zwei hälften seien eine hälfte zu platon
eine hälfte des kaders ort ließ
und man muss zwei fragen beantworten
eine frage von jeder hälfte also man
muss sagen dass man ein bisschen über
platten besteht ein bisschen hat der
satellit und natürlich sind die
hauptthemen die die ich in der vorlesung
aber betrachtet habe versprochen ist es
auch dass man meinen dass das männern
und die ethik relevant sind denn die
sitzen die zwei texte die in dem
tutorial gesprochen würden oder gelesen
worden
aber es gibt es wird mehrere fragen zu
jenen für das aufgeben nicht nur eine ok
hat jemand fragen zur klausur gut so die
kanadische ethik oft sagt man einfach
die ethik des ortes es gibt aber zwei
bücher von aristoteles namens ethik
nämlich die nico magische ethik und die
einheimischen nach nico markus sein sohn
und über dem ort noch dazu kommt es dass
drei bücher in beiden ethik werken also
bild im sinne von wie kapiteln tauchen
in beiden werken auf also es gibt die so
genannte gemeinen nicht gemeine bücher
aber die gemeinsame bücher die in die
chromatischen unité mission dann
auftauchen
es gibt ist eine angesprochenes thema
und viel besprochen das thema wie genau
diese zwei werke geschrieben wurden
wieso es ist dass matthias drei kapiteln
in beiden haushalten also ein bisschen
komisch
es wird besprochen welches zuerst
geschrieben würde und so weiter und so
fort das ist für uns nicht so wichtig
was sie wissen müssen essen vielleicht
nur oder wollen ist vielleicht nur dass
es mehr als ein werk so etwas wie es
gibt aber das werk das alle lesen ist
die kroatische ethik es gibt dann auch
ein weiteres werk was vielleicht nicht
so interessant ist nämlich die magna
moral die auch etwas fraglich ist ob er
das salbe verschrieben hat als ist aber
auf jeden fall aristotelische ich habe
dann auf dem herrn dort habe ich die
themen denn sind der zehn büchern als
der nico matic aufgelistet um zu zeigen
welche welche die hauptfragen oder
themen bei alles dort ließ tätig sind
das erste buch ist wahrscheinlich das
meistgelesene buch und ist eine
erklärung der methode und
wissenschaftliches status der ethik also
hier geht es vorwiegend darum zu fragen
inwiefern ethik eine wissenschaft ist
welche art von wissenschaft ist das wie
verhält das mit anderen wissenschaften
in der philosophie ersten stars und
zweitens führt er sein haupt thema und
eine hauptfrage nämlich glückseligkeit
das wort für glückseligkeit ist harmonie
und da so ist das pflicht zu sagen wenn
man dieses wort einführt erstens dass
dieses wurde das wort diamond beinhaltet
drei mann heißt damon also heißt themen
also ein übermenschlicher geist oder
sowas
also buchstäblich heißt bei den eher
sowas wie von dance ist man der spirit
also bei heißt gut also gute beziehung
zu die spirit über der welt zu haben
so grob und das klingt sehr religiös
diese färbung des wortes kommt selten
nur selten bei des ortes vor
für ihn heißt es wird nur glückseligkeit
aber zweiter punkt den man immer macht
zu dem mord ist das alter manier eine
etwas andere bedeutung hat als das
englische wort happiness oder die
deutsche das deutsche wort glücklich
kite und glück oder glück vielleicht
sogar glückseligkeit glückseligkeit ist
wahrscheinlich besser als glück das hat
sehr wenig oder nicht mindestens nicht
nur mit einer subjektiven gefühl zu tun
dass man glücklich ist also das halt
nichts oder fast nichts hat so sein wie
man jetzt auf neudeutsch sagt ich bin
heute gern ganz happy es heißt nicht
dass man gut gelaunt ist oder dass man
es sogar dass man zufrieden ist man
könnte mit dem leben zufrieden sein
sehr zufrieden sogar ohne glücklich oder
glückselig zu sein
in der station bedeutung sergio ramos
ist befürchte ich
sehr glücklich nach dem normalen
sprachgebrauch und sehr zufrieden mit
seinem leben er ist aber alles außer
heute einen in der ästhetischen sinne
angenommen dass er die tugend nicht
besetzt also die das ist sozusagen wenn
man heute iphone ist also glückselig das
heißt dass man sozusagen objektiv
gesehen als mensch erfolgreich ist und
das hat nichts nichts eigentlich nichts
mit dem service der selbsteinschätzung
zu tun weil böse menschen oft menschen
sind die mit sich sehr zufrieden sind
denken wir an donald trump es gibt die
es gibt kaum ein mensch auf der erde der
zufriedener ist mit sich selbst als
download vom obwohl es wenige menschen
in der welt gibt die wenige glückselig
since nach der ästhetischen bedeutung
und wir alle bekannten die zum mini jobs
sind in dieser beziehung mindestens ok
buch zwei bis fünf haben mit den tag mit
der praktischen tugenden zu tun und
besprühte auch sehr interessanter weise
das thema der freiwilligkeit
hier nochmals die übersetzung schwierig
was er meint ist es ist nicht gegen
meine wille irgendwas zu tun sondern
meiner seele nach also ich mache das
freiwillig es geht hier aber nicht
eigentlich nichts darum das problem der
freiheit zugesprochen wird manchmal wird
das so gelesen aber das ist meiner
meinung nach kein guter ansatz zu den
text was er hier er bespricht ist sowas
wie die bedingungen für
verantwortlichkeit und eine bedingung
ist dass ich für eine handlung nur
verantwortlich bin
wenn es nicht gegen meinen
zb wenn ich gezwungen wenn irgendwas zu
tun
geld das nicht alles freiwillig und
deswegen bin ich nicht dafür
verantwortlich
zum beispiel daran nehmen wir an sie
sind alle wütend wegen der regen
niederlage deutschlands
und sie wollen das irgendwie ausüben ja
gut und dann denken sie
wir finden einen ausland und wir zeigen
hier und da der unglückliche ausländer
bin ich also sie nehmen sie nehmen mich
in die armen werfen mich aus dem fenster
und ich lande auf herr huber der leiter
der universität wird verfilmt oder
vielleicht ist vielleicht das beispiel
ich lande auf eine großmutter eine nette
großmutter und sie wird umgebracht ich
nichts ich bin also diese würde sagen
ich bin nicht für diesen für diese
dieses morde bin ich nicht
verantwortlich weil ich unfreiwillig aus
dem fenster geworfen denn wenn ich
freiwillig also weil ich wollte wenn ich
aus dem fenster gesprungen werde dann
war das nicht gegen meine welle
andererseits muss man nach alles auch
wissen was man tut also ist es ein
beispiel ist wenn man in einem
schwertkampf ist und man wollte nur üben
aber der schweren der schweiz sollte
stumpf sein ist aber scharf und wenn man
den anderen stärkt und ihn umbrachte
bringt dass es auch nicht dann ist man
auch nicht verantwortlich obwohl man das
freiwillig gemacht hat weil man
unwissend war also wir haben diese
bedingungen für verantwortlichkeit
freiwilligkeit und wissen dann gibt es
fälle wo es schwierig zu sagen ist
obmann verantwortlich ist oder nicht das
ist wirklich interessant und ist
irgendwie schon wichtig für die spätere
geschichte der des problems der
freiwilligkeit oder der freie wille dass
es aber irgendwie nur ein neben eine
nebenfrage für ihn geht es hauptsächlich
darum zu sagen
unter welchen bedingungen man ethisch
verantwortlich ist auch bespricht ja
hier die verschiedene tugend und dazu
werde kommen wenn wir beispiele sehen
was er als tugend also wohl unter erd
und besteht dann sehen wir dass es auch
intellektuelle tugend gibt zum beispiel
weisheit oder schlauheit für ihn hat das
menschliches sei das menschliche leben
irgendwie zwei seiten
man spricht auch von einer theoretischen
seite und einer praktischen seite
praktische tugendhat mit mehr oder
weniger alltägliche handlungen zu tun
also wie man mit anderen menschen umgeht
so praktisches leben das ist was wir
unter ethik normalerweise verstehen
für ihn hat aber ethik auch mit
intellektueller trugen zu tun also die
fähigkeit philosophie zu machen oder
einfach mal gemeinden zu denken
und deswegen besteht ja auch hier
intellektuelle tugend hier beschädigte
auch das ist ja interessant ich werde
dazu zu bekommen willensschwäche und
lust also also willensschwäche oder
acacia heißt buchstäblich so was wie
fällen die selbstbeherrschung und oder
wellen schwäche also wird es oft
übersetzt die dir hier ist dass man weiß
was man machen sollte
also man mag man weiß wie man handeln
soll mach es macht es aber nicht weil
man zu willensschwach ist typisches
beispiel
ich weiß dass ich nicht zu viel essen
soll bei einer feier system mache ich
das irgendwie und ich bin dabei zu essen
so zu fressen
und sie fragen mich denken sie wirklich
dass sie sich so verhalten sollen und so
viel essen auf einmal und ich sage nein
ich weiß dass ich dann bauchweh später
haben werde
aber ich mache es trotzdem war es so gut
schmeckt oder so das ist aggressiv
das werden wir später wahrscheinlich
nächste woche da spricht er spricht hier
über lust oder hayden dass wir heute und
wohl nächste woche dann vorkommen
das ist für ihn sehr wichtig dass sie
wie sie sehen auf der liste wie sie auch
dann ist das sein können kommt ohne lust
zweimal vor
es kommt sogar kurz im ersten buch vor
wiedersehen wenn dann wird das
ausführlich im siebten buch gesprochen
und dann wieder im senken buch als sehr
viele über lust zu sagen wahrscheinlich
weil es andere philosophen jena in
seiner seitdem hat die hedonisten wollen
also ein hedonist ist jemand der glaubt
dass das höchste gut
oder das gut schlechthin hedone er ist
also lust das beste am leben oder das
wichtigste unternehmen oder das gut ja
neben ist lust und das will er wieder
legen dann gibt es zwei bücher zum thema
freundschaft verlieren wir auch nächste
woche besprechen
das ist interessant vor allem weil das
eine gelegenheit ist zu sehen wie welche
rolle verhältnisse und beziehungen zu
anderen menschen am besten leben spielen
nach asus und dann im zelt ein buch wie
gesagt geht es wiederum lust und dann
etwas überraschender weise sagte er am
ende
übrigens hat was vergessen dass ich
sagen das beste leben ist das leben der
des philosophierens nachdem man nach
neuneinhalb bürger den eindruck hat dass
das beste legen vorwiegend mit praktisch
gut also mit guter handlungen
praktischer tugend zu tun hat also sehr
überraschend und wir sehen werden können
das wäre die nächste woche beschränken
gibt es streit innerhalb der gäste ließ
forschung wie man diese letzte hälfte
des buchs sehen
mit der restlichen ethik dann zu
vereinbaren es ist wirklich sehr
problematisch ok heute werden wir aber
vorwiegend nur das erste buch zu
besprechen und dann ein bisschen von der
diskussion der tugend in buch 2 bis 5
und wie gesagt ist das erste thema was
alles auf wirkt die frage was die ethik
ist als wissenschaft vielleicht sollte
jetzt dass wir schon in der stimmung für
ethnologie sind das wort kommt von ethos
und das heißt so was wie charakter
gewohnheit und das ist schon in diesem
fall ist der titel wirklich nicht
irreführend weil für ihn ethik will ich
wirklich darum geht also wie man sich
benimmt der gewohnheit nach
das ist wie ein sehr sozial diese idee
übrigens ich weiß nicht ob ich das
vorher schon gesagt habe aber die titel
die wir in diesem für diese verschiedene
werke von alice haben sind fast immer
von später sie wurden später naturen
erfunden
jetzt kommt manchmal vor dass alles ort
ließ auf eine werk hinweis mit einer
titel zum beispiel als wir letzte woche
haben wir erste und zweite analytiker
gesprochen und jedes wort kommt bei sony
selbst vor
aber es nicht immer unbedingt der fall
dass dort ließ der den titel des werkes
ausgewählt hat also da muss man
vorsichtig sein
habe hier wie gesagt ist das eigentlich
gar nicht irreführend
und das erste was er sagt zur frage von
ethik aus wissenschaft ist eben dass das
schon eine wissenschaft ist und zwar
eine politische wissenschaft
hier sehen wir dass alles okay ist
eigentlich ein gros ein größeres projekt
folge hat was auf aus zwei hälften
besteht so sagen weil wir zuerst die
kritik haben oder in diesem fall wie
thematische ethik und dann die politik
und was es wird auch sehr klar am ende
des senken buchers hier in der ethik
dass er ein herz schreibtisch einen
übergang zum nächsten werk und das
nächste werk ist die politik die wir
kurz gesprochen haben als wir frauen bei
dass dieses besprochen haben
vor mehreren wochen also seine idee ist
nachdem man das alles gelesen hat weiß
man was das beste leben ist schon das
klingt schon ziemlich wichtig aber das
was hier klar wird selbst im ersten
kapitel und fahren wenn man beide werke
zusammen direkt wird es klar dass er
vorhat dass politiker verstehen sollen
was das beste leben für alle menschen
ist vor allem für die bürger seiner
stadt
und er soll gesetze einsetzen und die
gesellschaft so gestalten dass alle
bürger dieses beste leben dann
realisieren können und deswegen ist das
eine politische wissenschaft das hat mit
dem leben in der polis zu tun kolles
also sieht das wie sie wahrscheinlich
wissen von politik von
alles starrt auf griechisch trotzdem
kann man so einen gewissen grade sagen
ethik hat mit das leben der ist von von
jedem in die welt individuellen mensch
zu tun
die politik hat mit der ganzen
gesellschaft zu tun
manchmal vor allem in der späteren
aristotelischen tradition wird
praktische philosophie in drei teile
gegliedert
es gibt zig dass die wird dass die
wissenschaftler des individuums und es
gibt politik das ist die wissenschaft
für die stadt oder für den staat aber in
griechenland geht es wirklich um eine
stadt wie athen und in der mitte gibt es
die wissenschaft des haushaltes ökonomik
das wort ökonomik es hat mit dem was zu
tun war großes haus auf griechisch also
theoretisch soll sollte man ein zweites
werk hier in der mitte gehabt haben wo
es um haushalt und familie geht das hat
es nicht geschrieben
es gibt aber spätere werke in der
antiken philosophie die ökonomik
bestreiten
und natürlich spielt es ein bisschen im
ersten buch der politik aber im grunde
genommen ist eine praktische philosophie
so aufgebaut individuum gesellschaft die
idee und die sind zusammen sehr eng
verbunden diese zwei projekte
beziehungsweise ist das eigentlich nur
ein projekt und die idee sagt zuerst
zeigen weil abend wie welches leben wir
anstreben sollen mehr oder weniger damit
dass politiker es ermöglichen können
dass leute dieses leben erfolgreich
anstreben das ist das ziel
und hier ist das ist wirklich meiner
meinung nach hilfreich wenn man sich
fragt was das publikum dieses werkes war
also was ist ein ziel
als autor wie ich vorher gesagt habe vor
ein paar wochen als ich alles hatte ist
eingeführt habe es soll man meiner
meinung nach nicht unbedingt davon
ausgehen dass alle werke von atos origin
für die gleiche zusammenhang für den
gleichen zusammenhang geschrieben wurden
oder für das gleiche publikum sogar zum
beispiel wenn man ein werk wie über die
seele nimmt oder vor allem die mathe
physik super super schwierig sehr schwer
zu lesen sehr kompliziert sehr abstrakt
und wenn man das mit der ethik
vergleicht man spürt irgendwie das
vielleicht verschiedene publikums
mitglieder vorher gesehen sind es kann
trotzdem sein dass in beiden fällen dass
wir sozusagen
texte die aus einer vorlesung
hervorkommen oder aus irgendeiner
lehrveranstaltung die in seiner schule
stattgefunden hat dass es nicht nur
wahrscheinlich sondern fast sicher aber
man könnte sich vorstellen dass das
publikum für ein allgemeines publikum
war als das für mathe physik zum
beispiel oder sogar über die serie wurde
die logik dass manchmal stelle ich mir
vor dass die ernsthafte studierende
waren am vormittag haben logik und
wetterfest gemacht und dann am
nachmittag hat mein ethik und politik
gemacht also nach nachdem die fans
studierende so reingekommen sind aber
müssen natürlich schwer zu sagen
das andere was er auch sehr interessant
über ethik als wissenschaftstag sagt ist
dass die ethische wissenschaft nicht so
genau ist wie andere wissenschaften
wir haben schon gesehen wie eine
wissenschaft nach alles okay so
ausschauen soll das haben wir letzte
woche gesehen
das soll aus theoretisch mindestens das
soll aus
bestehen wo man von ersten prinzipien
ausgeht und dann durch eine kette von
logisch annehmbar der schlüssel dann von
diesen unmittelbaren ersten prinzipien
so vermittelte dedizierte schlüssel
kommt dass es so sollte eine
wissenschaft ausschauen
also man könnte vielleicht denken dass
sein vorbild für eine wissenschaft werde
so was wie die elementen von liquid das
ist genau was macht mehr oder wenn ihr
also definitionen das sind die erste
prinzipien und aus diesen definitionen
beweist er weitere thesen
es ist nicht der fall dass alle sorten
die sich normalerweise in seinen werken
so vorgeht bzw ist eigentlich nie der
fall dass er vorgeht dass es noch mal
ein problem was in der ressortforschung
sehr oft diskutiert wird das heißt man
fragt sich wieso ist es das nachdem er
diese dieses werk die zweite nötig
geschrieben hat wo er darstellt wie eine
perfekte wissenschaft aufgebaut werden
soll
wieso schreibt ja dann all diese andere
werke die völlig andere eine völlig
andere methode haben
das ist ein schwieriges problem was ich
jetzt nicht lösen lösen werde
aber wir können wir können vielleicht
vermuten mindestens dass es deswegen ist
dass er entweder weil er hier in einer
situation ist wo er mit studierenden
spricht die von nichts von ersten
prinzipien ausgehen weil sie vielleicht
diese erste prinzipien gar nichts
begriffen haben sondern haus nahe
liegende prämisse ausgehen will also er
nimmt plausible prämisse und baut darauf
seine wissenschaft vielleicht weil es um
erziehung hier geht oder so dass es
pädagogisch gedacht oder verleiht hat es
irgendwas mit dialektische methode zu
tun dass es naheliegend wenn man bei
beträgt das machen wie wir in der in
über die seele und in der physik fängt
er hofft damit an dass er die meinungen
von anderen philosophen bespricht
dann gibt es eine dialektische
auseinandersetzung mit diesen anderen
thesen sie sagen den theorien von
anderen philosophen und dann geht er
langsam zu seiner theorie das ist eher
die normale art ästhetische
vorgehensweise die etliche ist ähnlich
also es gibt kein erstes buch tätig wo
er alle theorien der ethik bespricht bis
platon aber er erwähnt schon sehr oft in
diesem buch wie wir sein werden was die
so sagen
typische einnahmen im ethischen leben
sind und sagt sogar dass man eigentlich
schon die richtige kritische
einstellungen haben so sollte bevor man
ethik studiert deswegen sagt er das 1 1
ein junge eine junge person ist noch
nicht geeignet
patrick zu lernen das betrifft also die
die sogenannte so sollen normale bl
studierende die hier anwesend sind sind
wahrscheinlich zu jung für dieses thema
nach alles sollte dieses auffassung man
sollte vielleicht funden und 30 sein
oder so nichts weglaufen trotzdem
sie sind wahrscheinlich reifer als die
junge den menschen in der station seitz
aber der grund dafür ist wirklich
interessant was er hier geht davon aus
dass leute schon die richtige ethische
intuitionen haben müssen oder
überzeugungen überhaupt diese
lehrveranstaltungen zu verfolgen das ist
die idee und das ist noch mal ein
zeichen dass er hier
also wer in dem publikum setzt das hängt
damit zusammen was ich vorher gesagt
habe über dieses politisches projekt
wovon die ethik nur die erste hälfte ist
also meine vermutung ist dass das
publikum aus mitglieder besteht die im
politischen leben mindestens etwas aktiv
sind also die sind frei natürlich sind
sie freiburger und männer weil sonst
also dass wir gar nicht möglich in athen
damalige athen
aber das sind wirklich leute die schon
eine bestimmte idee haben wie das leben
ausschauen soll und die schon die tuben
schätzen sehr schätzen also wenn man
diese leute die sind wie diese herren
die sorge dies immer begegnet in den
frühen dialogen also in wohlhabende
männer reiche vielleicht sogar reiche
männer also staatsmänner generale dicht
solche leute also erhabene griechen und
sie haben schon eine bestimmte
vorstellung wie das richtige leben
ausschauen soll das ist ein leben der
tugend und hat dort ließ im gegensatz
zur sekretärin nichts sagen er hat keine
ahnung
er will sagen ihr habt eine ahnung und
ich zeige euch wieso diese ahnung mehr
oder weniger richtig ist und auf welche
prinzipien diese handlungen saison
gebaut sind also sie haben schon
eigentlich die die richtige erwartungen
wie ein gutes leben aushandeln soll und
ich zeige euch wieso das ist eine
erklärung von dem was wir schon glauben
als das publikum und das erklärt unter
anderem warum ethische skeptizismus
überhaupt nicht vorkommt bei aristoteles
ist nicht weil er antike philosoph ist
der keine ahnung vom relativismus oder
skeptizismus hat denken wir an platon in
platin kommt es dauern vor
es gibt all dieses sophisten die dann
rein kommen und sagen ich glaube dass
der mächtige immer recht hat oder ich
glaube ich sollte das machen was mir
spaß macht
also das sind die typischen thesen der
sophisten die von sorgen diese widerlegt
werden hatte ließ hat keine interesse an
solche leute
er spricht mit an wir den griechen an
den athena die richtige einstellung
haben und der grund wofür ich sage dass
das wahrscheinlich entweder staatsmänner
oder wert werde werde gern staatsmänner
sein sollten ist eben dieses politisches
projekt also mal nach meiner vorstellung
sitzen leute da die sozusagen jetzt die
vorlesungen und später gehen sie runter
und stimmen ab in jan dem staatsrat also
ist mehr oder weniger die situationen
die ich mir vorstelle
er ist sagt auch da ist also das ist
eine praktische wissenschaft mit einem
praktischen zweck und setzt voraus dass
man eben diese richtige meinungen oder
überzeugen hat das ist irgendwie eine
man könnte sagen dass es eine
einschränkung des projektes er will zum
beispiel nichts alles auf erste
prinzipien begründen die man gar nicht
infrage stellen kann das kommt überhaupt
nicht vor und was weiß auch was er auch
selber sagt ist wie gesagt dass diese
wissenschaft nicht so genau erst wie man
sich vorstellen könnte
wenn man sowas wie mathematik denkt also
wenn man da rein kommt aus politiker und
man meint ich werde jetzt hören wie man
das leben der tugend dann begründen kann
genau wie heute die geometrie in seinen
elementen begründet hat diese erwartung
werde falsch nach alles ort ließ in der
grün wofür das falsch ist es wirklich
sehr interessant und glaube ich glaube
wer also seinen punkt ist wirklich sehr
überzeugend das problem mit dem
ethischen leben ist das politische leben
sehr verschieden ist und als sehr schwer
vorherzusehen zu sein also es war
kommunalen mögliche situationen vor und
man kann nicht pauschal lösungen im
voraus anbieten für alle situationen die
vorkommen könnten
gehen wir zurück zu diesem fußball
beispiel also ich bin ein verteidiger
wahl kommt rein
ich weiß dass ich hoch springen muss
aber ich muss auch einschätzen wie
historisch springen und vor allem mit
wievielen gewalt gegen mein gegner
wenn ich überhaupt kein gewalt einsätze
ist das falsch also ich muss nicht
schüchtern sei es ich muss wirklich
ich muss versuchen ihn von den ball weg
zu drängen und nun mein bestes zu tun
aber ohne so viel einsatz zu zeigen war
das werde dann eine fahrt und kann man
kann man sozusagen regeln dann
hinschreiben genau wie man das machen
sollte nein oder ja für die die keinen
sport mögen kann es regen geben wie viel
man bei einem hessen hessen sollte
vielleicht können sie sagen ja doch also
kein kalorienzählen und ich weiß genau
wie viele hessen sollte aber sie zu
allen situationen sind sehr verschieden
vielleicht weiß ich dass ich später an
dem abend nicht zu fassen kriegen werde
vielleicht muss ich höflich sein und ein
bisschen mehr essen weil damit mein
gastgeber nicht denkt dass das mir nicht
schmeckt vielleicht so nicht mehr heißen
obwohl das mir nicht schmeckt weil ich
höflich sein muss vielleicht will ich
dass die andere den eindruck haben wir
bekommen das sie so viel essen dürfen
wie sie wollen deswegen er sich auch
mehr
und so weiter und so fort das ist nur
essen
es ist wirklich sehr das wissen sie alle
wurde wirklich sehr sehr schwierig
manchmal so wissen genau wie viel man
erstens sollte und die idee ist wie wir
sehen werden und die schon vorher gesagt
habe
die idee ist mehr oder weniger der
tugendhafte mensch ist jemand der ein
gefühl hat für wie viel man in dieser
situation ist aber situationen sind sehr
verschieden und deswegen kann man keine
pauschale grundprinzipien oder regen
es gibt keinen letzte was für alle
situationen passt und deswegen kann er
diesen nur grob und allgemein
beschreiben wie das beste leben ist
man könnte sagen es ist ein botschaft
ist mehr oder weniger eine abstrakte
beschreibung der richtigen handlung zu
geben die nicht ausreichen werde um
herauszufinden was in jeder situation
die richtige handlung wäre also er kann
erklären wie es ist oder welche art von
person richtige entscheidungen trifft
zum beispiel beim hessen was er nicht
machen kann ist zu sagen genau wie viel
man hessen sollte in jeder situation
übrigens was auf eine wand ist nicht nur
die situationen die verschieden sind
personen sind auch verschieden
und hier gibt er den beispiel von milo
wieder war ein einen ring also ein
großer mächtiger olympische sportler wie
sergio ramos
das war eigentlich was er mit namen
gemacht hat es zu bringen statt fußball
sergio ramos muss zweifellos mehr essen
hastig also erst so groß also er neben
mir ist ein
seither ist er ein gigant wenn er so
viel essen würde wie ich würde eher zu
wenig essen wenn ich so viel wie er
essen würde
viel zu viel essen in beiden mal in
beiden fällen schlecht also die
situationen sind verschieden und die
handel personen sind auch verschieden
aber deswegen es wirklich schwierig zu
sagen wie man vorher gehen soll
ich finde diese überlegung nicht nur
plausibel sondern wirklich sehr sehr
wichtig als beobachtung wegen der
erwartungen die wir oft von ethik haben
mein denken sie an angewandte ethik im
allgemeinen oder unsere tendenz zu
denken dass die ethiker derjenige ist
der sehr schwierige entscheidungen
richtigen treffen kann zb der die beste
chancen hat richtig die frage zu
beantworten sollten wir diese person
noch am leben halten
trotz dieser krankheit sollen wir
abtreibung erlauben sollen wir mit anna
sie heute nah sich erlauben was ist
unsere einstellung zu lassen jetzt also
all diese schwierige fälle
und ich glaube dass wir oft irgendwie
davon ausgehen dass der beste ethiker
und das die beste ästhetische theorie
genau die theorie ist die die schwierige
fälle lösen kann
das was alles sollte das hier sagt
schließt nicht aus dass tun hat die
menschen auch in schwierigen fällen die
richtige entscheidung treffen dass das
passt sogar sehr gut zu seiner theorie
also zb man könnte in einer sehr
komplizierten situationen sein
also ich habe wenig hunger würde aber
von meinem chef eingeladen
aber ich weiß dass seine frau auch keine
hunger hat aber mein sohn ist auch hier
und er ist ein bisschen er wird immer
dünner und ich will dass er mehr ist und
nun also iks viele komplizierte faktoren
die ich dann ein irgendwie einschätzen
muss um herauszufinden wie viel ich
essen sollte wenn ich ein tugendhafter
mensch bin würde ich nach rades ort ließ
die richtige entscheidungen treffen oder
die richtige meinung mängel nehmen
aber es liegt jenseits der möglichkeit
der ethischen theorie solche probleme zu
lösen
wie könnt ihr mir sehr gut vorstellen
dass denn wenn alles so verfallen davon
erfahren würde dass wir heutzutage ist
zb sitzungen haben wo ethiker so
rumsitzen und einen ein krankenhaus dann
bereits wie sie vorgehen sollten
er würde wahrscheinlich sagen warum
nehmen sie nicht irgendwie einfach
irgendwelche gute menschen und sie
werden das praktische dinge ehrgefühl
dann einsetzen und dadurch die richtige
entscheidung schaffen
es gibt sehr wenig was der ethiker hier
machen kann was der ethiker machen kann
ist so eine theorie so liefern die
erklärt wieso der gute glückseliger
mensch glücklich ist oder wie das
ausschaut zu sein
das finde ich irgendwie bescheiden und
auch hier vielleicht richtig so wie ich
habe mehrmals gesagt habe ist das
hauptthema
oder habt begriff der ethik heute
armenier glückseligkeit und hier würde
das alles hier sagt das ist fast ein
bisschen lustig sagt
also es ist einfach offensichtlich dass
wir hier herausfinden müssen was das
beste leben ist das ist unser ziel als
ethiker und das ist natürlich das leben
wo man alle drei monate das leben wo man
glückselig ist aber dass das beste neben
mit ein ein glückliches leben zu
identifizieren ist ist so offensichtlich
dass das gar nicht interessant ist
also wir müssen irgendwie aus
buchstabieren was es ist glückselig zu
sein
das ist praktisch sozusagen sein erster
schritt ist ein es gar kein scherz sagt
einfach so per definitionem geht es in
ethik zu sagen was das glückselige leben
ist aber dann damit hat er was gemacht
was aus uns in den augen fast dass es
das ist was die these indes ganten dem
ganzen werk was für uns am
überraschendsten ist es wirklich sehr
kontrovers aus unseren augen immer ein
ist wenn wir normalerweise sagen in der
ethik geht es darum herauszufinden wie
man glückselig werden kann würden wir
nicht eher so was sagen wie in der ethik
geht es darum herauszufinden wie wir
unsere pflicht erfüllen oder was unsere
vierte sind oder was oder zum beispiel
vielleicht würden wir sagen in der ethik
müssen wir herausfinden oder wollen wir
herausfinden was wir anderen menschen
schalten oder sowas und das ist
frankreich nicht das kommt gar nicht in
frage
für ihn ist es einfach offensichtlich
dass es dass es um mich geht in der
ethik was ich machen soll und muss wenn
ich über ethik
denke ist herausfinden wie ich der beste
ich werden kann wie möglich oder also
wie ich glückselig werden kann
hier hilft es ein bisschen zu bemerken
das weiß ich schon gesagt habe
es geht hier nicht ums zufriedenheit
oder glücklich kite in diesem subjektiv
mit dieser subjektiven bedeutung dass
ich hab i denn es geht um so was wie ein
blühendes leben zu haben oder ein
erfolgreiches leben also ist mehr
objektiv was das aber trotzdem scheint
das sehr eigensinnig also es scheint
dass wenn ich wenn ich ein ethik denke
nach art des ortes denke ich nur daran
wie kann ich der ein perfekter peter
harms in sein
das ist also das verkleiden vergleich
was einfällt ist noch mal so was wie
sportler also ethik ist wie sport aber
wichtiger es ist der beste zu sein
der beste mensch den es geben kann das
ist das ziel und das ist wenn ich das
sagen darf das ist sehr alt griechisch
also diese idee dass man fast wie ein
held durch das leben dann gehen soll als
ein perfekter mensch und das dass das
ziel der ethik ist das ist sehr fern von
den erwartungen der die wir
normalerweise in der ethik haben also
wenn man konsequent alles muss denkt
oder oder kann celtic da geht es
überhaupt nicht darum der perfekte
glückselige menschen seien da gab es da
geht es darum herauszufinden was wir
machen sollen also was sind die susan
regeln oder was ist die pflicht wie und
was muss ich machen damit ich nicht
falsch zu sagen das ist nicht alles auch
diese einstellungen und hier sei nicht
allein
man kann sogar im allgemeinen sein dass
die ganze antike tätig simonis tisch ist
also auch andere theoretiker platon die
story die apple korea die spätere
platonischer die gehen alle davon aus
dass unser ziel als ethiker das ist das
beste leben zu beschreiben was für alle
anstrebenswert erst zum beispiel wenn
man hedonist ist die these die man
vertretet ist das beste leben für dich
und für mich für jeden ist das leben wo
man das meiste lust genießt weil das
einfach das beste leben ist nicht damit
nicht also die idee es nicht irgendwie
hedonismus zu begründen weil es für
andere nützlich ist oder sowas ist auch
nicht nur total närrisch also nicht ganz
so ganz lässt das licht wie mail oder
band an
die idee ist nicht lust für alle zu
maximieren die idee ist für mich und das
hier haben das hat alles ein vorteil um
einen nachteil
der nachteil ist offensichtlich es
scheint dass ein minister tätig das
problem hat zu sagen wieso ich um das
sehr einfach haus zu dürfen wie es auch
ich nett sein soll also wie das trifft
das betrifft nicht als ethischer agents
gar nichts wie es ihnen geht alles was
ich überlegen muss ist wie es mir geht
und wenn ich nett bin oder großzügig
dann bin ich noch ned oder großzügig
weil ich ein großzügiger mensch sein
will aber nicht ihnen nicht ihnen das
geht nicht darum dass es ihnen gut geht
es geht wirklich nicht wirklich darum
nur dass es mir gut geht und
großzügigkeit also nach dieser
auffassung scheint dass das
großzügigkeit ist ein fall wo ich meine
mitmenschen
als instrumente nehmen und als
gelegenheit nehme um eine tugend der
großzügigkeit auszuüben
also sie geben mir alle nur eine chance
großzügig zu sein
aber was ist wenn die größe geben also
wenn die geldscheine zum beispiel
es geht nicht darum dass sich diese
leute helfen will oder vielleicht doch
aber ich will diese leute nur helfen
weil ich so ein person eine person sein
will die andere personen hält aber nicht
letztendlich damit es den anderen gut
geht das ist eigentlich das ist das
problem
es gibt aber einen sehr starken vorteil
einer der minister stetig nämlich
folgendes wenn man zum beispiel daher
kommt und sagt wir sollen alle das tun
was für die was maximal für die meisten
leute plötzlich erst was aber wenn man
öffentlichkeit ist deswegen der termin
dann könnte ich sagen will ich nicht was
sollte er sagen also dann sagt er habe
dann bist du ein böser mensch
okay was jetzt
oder kannst du musst deine pflicht
erfüllen muss ich nicht will nicht aber
das ist doch deine pflicht und dann bist
du nicht rational und aber was soll er
sagen er kann nichts sagen es gibt
sozusagen keine eingebaute motivation
mit dass mindestens ein möglich also ich
sage nicht dass mörder oder krank das
gar nicht dieses problem gar nicht lösen
kann
mein punkt ist dass alles okay ist das
problem nicht hat und im allgemeinen hat
ein titel der minister ethik dieses
problem nicht weil es offensichtlich
erst dass ich ein grund habe der beste
mix zu sein wie ich werden kann
oder anders gesagt es ist offensichtlich
30 glückselig sein will
die idee der nein ich bin lieber
unglücklich was also das ist wirklich
sinnlos
vielleicht wenn jemand also buchstäblich
verrückt werde
könnt ihr das vorkommen aber jeder
gesunde mensch will glückselig sein und
wenn er wirklich sein kann dass die
touren mit glückseligkeit zusammenhängt
dann haben wir intern hinter theorie
nicht nur eine motivation tugend
hauswänden sondern die beste motivation
die es geben kann
und das trifft bei kant und nicht ein
also dass also die haben ein problem
das alles sollte dies nicht hat
andererseits können kant und vor allem
mehr sagen dass sie eine sehr gute
erklärung haben wieso diätetik umarmte
den menschen geht während für heute an
ist die bedrohung besteht dass man
wirklich sehr eigensinnig denkt okay
dass so viel zu gut harmoniere und warum
das wichtig ist und warum das ein
zentraler begriff seine ethik ist okay
was ist jetzt mit einem heute eine große
frage
schwer zu sagen sagt er hat es dort ließ
aber wir können das mindestens abstrakte
sehr grobe schreiben wenn wir bemerken
dass glückseligkeit zwei eigenschaften
haben muss
nämlich glückseligkeit ist erstens also
in alleingang genug zu sagen
das heißt wenn man glückselig ist
braucht man nichts mehr
das heißt übrigens nicht unbedingt dass
man als mensch aus das heißt also die
idee ist nicht der der gute mensch ist
ein mensch der auf einer insel ohne
andere menschen leben könnte wie wir
sehen werden sollte der gute mensch
sogar freunde haben muss er sogar haben
aber der gute mensch ist auch nach außen
wir sehen ist auch jemand der am
wenigsten andere menschen braucht aber
das ist hier nicht die primäre bedeutung
die primäre bedeutung ist dass
glückseligkeit ausreichend ist allein
ausreichend und glückseligkeit ist final
und hier können wir vielleicht an seine
vier ursachen theorie denken also
materie von effizient effizient ursache
und final ursache im allgemeinen die ihr
gesehen haben gibt es erklärungen oder
ursachen die irgendwas erkennt dadurch
dass man ein zweck identifiziert zum
beispiel sind sie hier
damit sie eine vorlesung erhöhen können
und sie sind in die u bahn gestiegen
wenn sie mit der bahn gekommen sind
damit sie zur vorlesung kommen ja also
wenn wenn ich wenn jemand sie gefragt
hätten
wieso steigen sie in die u-bahn sie
hätten ohne überlegen sagen können um
diese vorlesung zu sehen
vielen dank übrigens
aber nicht jeder zweck ist ein final
zweck also irgendwie schon also finale
heißt nur hat mit sex zu tun aber es
gibt ein es gibt zwecke die sozusagen
weiter weg sind oder die finale sind als
andere zwecke zum beispiel sie kaufen
eine ein ticket für die u bahn damit sie
in die u-bahn steigen können sie
steigende die u-bahn damit sie so die
uni erreichen
sie erreichen die uni damit sie die
vorlesung erleben können und vielleicht
war das schon war das passt schon zb die
senioren die hier sind haben
wahrscheinlich keine weitere vielleicht
keine weitere zwecke
sie wollen keine et ass punkte erwerben
oder während die die die us pay
studierende eingeschrieben sind sie sind
hier nicht nur weil die vorlesungen so
blendend wunderbar sind das natürlich
auch aber sie sind auch hier damit sie
vielleicht die klausur dann bestehen
können damit die tcs punkte erwerben
damit sie ein bier haben damit sie dann
was weiteres machen können was sie nur
oder besser mit diesem budget machen
können ja zb vielleicht wollen sie
promovieren
wieso wollen sie promovieren damit sie
bundesminister werden können
damit dann dafür müssen sie nicht einmal
die einige dissertation zu schreiben
also jetzt schon aber
das war wirklich eine sitzung die wir
vielleicht nicht aufnehmen sollen wir
das schneiden
ok so herr guttenberg und so weiter und
man könnte sich fragen wenn all diese
zwecke nur mittel sind soweit ihre
zwecke gibt es dann ein endzweck gibt es
einen zweck aller zwecken
antwort ja heute also es selbst so was
wie heiraten könnte ein mittel sein wenn
man sich und das klingt ein bisschen
fies also ich hab sie nur verheiratet
als mittel und was zu erreichen
aber es ist irgendwie sinnvoll gesagt
haben ich habe das nur gemacht damit die
glückselig werde also und ich denke ein
leben mit dieser frau werden mich
glückseliger machen als ein leben ohne
sie ja also glückseligkeit ist die
ultimative ist der ultimative zweck alle
zu erklären dass und was übrigens hier
interessant ist ist alles so die
überzeugung dass wir eine ein
einheitlicher zweck für das ganze leben
haben und dass das für alle menschen
mindestens mehr oder weniger deshalb
wirst also wir wollen alle glückselig
werden
deswegen hat er dieses problem mit der
motivation nichts dafür alle ist sowieso
von haus aus glück serie wollen und alle
andere sachen nur ein mittel sind um
diese glückseligkeit zu erreichen
braucht er nichts zu sagen wieso wir
glückselig werden sollten
natürlich wollen wird glückselig sein
und es ist wirklich interessant zu sehen
dass er der überzeugung dass er sagen
kann dass das mindestens strukturell so
sagen für alle menschen gleich ist das
würde nicht heißen dass allen menschen
genau dasselbe leben führen sollten
wegen den betrachtungen die ich vorher
erwähnt habe situationen sind
verschieden und personen sind
verschieden
zum beispiel ist ein großer mächtiger
ringer ich nichts manche eine art von
leben nur die für ihn offen ist die für
mich nicht offen es ich kann kein
weltklassesportler werden wenn das nicht
alles zur enger weil ich zu klein bin ja
wenn mein traum gewesen wäre ein nba
basketball star zu sein hätte ich packe
hat also es als point guard wäre ich
hoffnungslos und leute die zum beispiel
sehr ungern lesen sind nicht geeignet
philosophieprofessor werden würde man
denken also personen sind verschieden
aus situationen sind verschieden zb wenn
ich in einer stadt wohnen die während
meines lebens von einem anderen staat
von einer handeln stadt angegriffen wird
dann beinhaltet das beste leben für mich
dass ich ihn einer in einem krieg
kämpfen soll und das soll ich tapfer
machen so weiter
vielleicht werde ich sterben aber das
gehört zudem dass neben für mich während
wenn ich so sagen glück hätte und in
einem nun ein friedliches in einem
friedlichen land leben könnte wäre das
beste leben ein leben ohne krieg gewesen
also je nachdem was vorkommt und wer man
erst ist das beste leben verschieden
aber nicht so verschieden dass wir
nichts mehr darüber sagen können wir
können was pauschales zu sagen darüber
sagen
nach welchen prinzipien oder vielleicht
dass er nach mit welcher werte das
bessere leben immer ausgeführt werden
kann
und hier gibt es mit
wie möglich mögliche werte oder
antworten auf diese frage es gibt denkt
aristoteles vier kandidaten also vier
leben für arten von leben die das beste
lebens sind das leben von denen die nur
lust haben wollen also die nur genießen
wollen
die die geld erwerben wollen
die die erde haben wollen und die die
die tugend erstreben das sind die vier
gängige theorien über das beste leben
und man sieht die seit die idee ist man
ist autark und hat etwas erreicht wofür
die wo man sozusagen den den letzten
zweck erworben hat wenn man lust geld er
der bruder tugend erreicht hat und die
frage ist was passt am besten zu unserer
intuitionen uns zu diese zwei
voraussetzungen
wieso diese 4 hier geht es zurück zu dem
was sie vorher gesagt habe über die
aristotelische methode ist eine methode
ist nichts mit leeren blatt papier
anzufangen zusammen
er nimmt an dass das publikum schon
sieht dass mehrere antworten auf diese
frage schon gestalt gestellt wurden und
plausibel sind also jeder hat irgendwie
die idee lust ist wichtig im leben
geldes wichtig im nebenher der super
wichtig in dem das inhaltlichen von
tugend auch alles gut also alle vier
bitte ja man könnte sich so vorstellen
dass das publikum so reagiert aber er
fragt hier könnte könnte man irgendwas
hier sind effizient als der zweck alle
zwecke
und dann deswegen kann er so vorgehen da
diese vier die konkurrierende
möglichkeiten sind kann er diese drei
ausschließen und dann ist er mit trugen
statement daraus die richtige antwort
dass sozusagen eine negative
vorgehensweise wo er durch eliminieren
auf die richtige antwort kommt aber dann
wäre der positiv begründen warum das
doch die richtige antwort ist also geht
in zwei schritten erstens streicht er
diese drei damit nur das bleibt und dann
sagt ja und es gibt gute gründe warum
das leben der tugend displays leben es
nämlich folgendes also erstens wie
schließt er die andere drei aus lust
werde ein passendes ziel für tiere und
da denkt man das ist deine antwort das
ist deine kritik an hedonismus man
denken wir an paaren anfang auch
hedonist unter den wichtigsten ethischen
denken aller zeit oder epikur es gibt
sehr wichtige kriterien die
hedonistischen und er ist als das ist
sein leben was für tiere dann passen
werden
und dann geht er einfach weiter ist sehr
enttäuschend und überraschend müssen
zum glück kommt der später auf das thema
also in die gesagt im denken hin siebten
buch also erklärt später warum lust
nicht das beste ziel ist aber ich würde
sagen dass das ist wirklich interessant
ist das ja das hier macht und es ist für
mich noch ein zeichen wer das publikum
erst das publikum ist kein publikum was
das herz traf nimmt als antwort und wenn
er es sollte also tiere
das ist also lust ist wird ihre wir sind
doch menschen die netten alle ja
natürlich weiter und dann er später
wieder zurückkommen geld und hier gibt
er meiner meinung nach eine widerlegung
des lebens das geld erwerbs was so
überzeugendes dass man das gar nicht
bestreiten kann
es sagt glückseligkeit ist ein final
zweck also ein zwerg was für keine
andere zwecke dient sondern das wetter
ist der letzte zweck für sich ist es das
was man an sich haben will
aber geld ist natürlich immer ein mittel
also man hat nur geld damit man ihn
sonst irgendwas erwerben kann zum
beispiel lust aber nicht mehr geld und
leute die nur geld an haufen damit sie
mehr geld haben das ist das skript von
chris chris menz karossen beispiel das
ist an sich ihre also es hat keinen sinn
weil geld kein spieler zweck ist es muss
andere werte oder ziele die man
erreichen will und deswegen hat man das
geld also gelderwerb es ist das hat
schließt nichts übrigens aus wie sie
sein werden
das geld und lust eine rolle in dessen
leben spielen
es liest aber heraus dass das beste
neben nur das leben des geld erwerbs ist
erde
hier ist eine antwort ähnlich er sagt
das problem mit das leben der erde ist
dass man
niemand will für das gehört für
irgendwas geehrt werden was nicht
wertvoll war zum beispiel da wenn ich
wenn er seinen krieg gibt und alle ehren
mich weil ich den schwarz gewonnen habe
aber das habe ich gar nicht gemacht dass
alles nur ein irrtum und die denken alle
ich war heldenhaft und so und die eher
fern mich aber eigentlich war ich hinter
eine mauer und haben mich verstärkt dann
würde ich nie denken ja das ist das
beste leben
also ich das heißt wenn ich erde schätze
was wird dort machen als möglichen dann
weil die erde ein zeichen ist von
irgendwas was ihm sonst irgendwas dass
ich habe das ehren wert erst und das ist
natürlich die tugend ok also diese drei
möglichkeiten sind ausgeschlossen
das leben der tun ist das beste leben
aber wieso jetzt kommt die positive
begründung für das leben der tugend und
das ist das sogenannte genannte
kernargument ergon heißt mehr oder
weniger funktionen oder werk und
vielleicht kennen sie das wort
ergonomisch zum beispiel das ist wirksam
oder das was effizienz ist eben
irgendetwas zu erreichen oder die die
funktion gut aussieht der schotte ließ
sagt wenn es ein ärgern für den mensch
gibt dann wäre der glückselige mensch
der beste mensch der menschen der diesen
ergon diese funktion gut erfüllt oder
ausübt genau wie zb ein flötenspieler
ist da ist jemand ein flötenspieler ist
jemand der gut flöte spielen kann oder
sogar gut flöte spielt nicht nur kann
oder ein auge hat eine funktion nämlich
zu sehen
und dann sagt er dass es interessant
könnte man einfach verneinen dass
menschen eine funktion haben
das ist doch sinnlos selbst die teile
der menschen haben zwecke oder
funktionen zum beispiel die hand oder
das auge
es kann nicht sein dass mein auge eine
funktion hat und meine hand eine
funktion hat ich aber nicht alle
natürliche dinge haben funktionen und
die funktion ist immer da dann sozusagen
der rhein berg oder eine tätigkeit die
nur dieses ding ausübt zum beispiel ein
flötenspieler ist genau das was gut
gespielt und auge ist genau das was
sieht also nur nur auge sieht dass es
der kundin wofür wir sagen dass die
funktion des augen zu sehen ist oder
messe messer ist zuschneiden vielleicht
es ist ein in einer bestimmten art und
weise wenn das eine bestimmte art messer
ist und alle natürliche dinge haben nach
resort ließ solche funktionen
das ist immer dann die funktionen die
nur dieses ding hat also wir suchen das
was den menschen eigen ist also
irgendwas was nur menschen machen und
das ist natürlich nicht sehen oder flöte
spielen sondern also wir brauchen
irgendwas was die was menschen von allen
anderen natürlichen dingen irgendwie
unterscheidet und das ist für hd suisse
vernunft
und hier sehen wir eine anspielung auf
das was wir in über die seele gesehen
haben sie ihren sich daran
es gibt verschiedene psychologische
fähigkeiten oder fell keinen die mit der
seele verbunden sind
wachstum fortpflanzung wahrnehmen
bewegung all diese fähigkeiten die wir
haben sind mit dem label anderen
lebewesen geteilt zum beispiel pflanzen
können sich fortpflanzen natürlich tiere
können wahrnehmen aber nur wir haben
vernunft deswegen ist unsere funktion
vernunft einzusetzen und das gut so ein
kleines genau wie der der vierte spieler
der seine funktion ausübt ist derjenige
der nicht nur führt er spielt sondern
gut spielt also die menschliche funktion
ist vernunft einzusetzen und in allen
bereichen wo man das machen kann und da
komme ich zurück zu meiner gliederung
der ethik es gibt diese zwei seiten des
lebens es gibt die praktische seite und
die theoretische seite
und wenn man die vernunft gut in
kritischen situationen einsetzt und gut
in theoretischen situationen einsetzt
also gut denkt und gut handelt dann ist
man ein mensch der die menschliche
funktion ausübt und dann ist man
glückselig dann ist man der beste mensch
den es geben kann und das ist unser ziel
nochmal so dass deswegen habe ich gesagt
das klingt ein bisschen eigensinnige was
ich machen will ist der beste mensch
sein wie möglich also dass das ging
etwas schneller aber das geht ja auch
bayer das original
da könnte man viele fragen dann auf
werden natürlich ist es wirklich wahr
dass diese das stiftungs das alles eine
funktion hat das natürliche sachen
wirklich eine funktion haben das genau
die die funktion himmel ist immer genau
das was dem ding eigen ist
das könnte man alles nachfragen aber das
ist ein argument und die frage für ihn
für die für den laster ethik ist dann
wie setzen wir vernunft ein
und jetzt kommen wir endlich zu die
praktische tugend und hier haben wie sie
wissen ist im allgemeinen verhalten ließ
die idee der tugend und dass man eine
mitte zwischen zwei extremen
identifiziert zum beispiel die richtige
menge zu essen ist nichts zu wenig zu
essen nicht zuviel oder höflichkeit ist
nichts ist nicht auf zu wenig zu sein
aber auch nicht kalt und so
zurückhaltend also man sollte diese
richtige mitte finden und das ist eine
funktion der vernunft
wie macht man das
man macht halt weil man die
tugendhat die vorher gesagt habe also
mein beispiel mit sergio ramos
der punkt war er weil er die wahl
lasterhafte ist machte einfach von 50
aus also eher der identifiziert zu sagen
haben wir die falsche handlung nicht
immer aber manchmal einfach als
charaktereigenschaft während eine
tugendhafte person die tugendhafte
handlung identifiziert mit der vernunft
aber ohne so kalkulieren also es geht
nicht um definieren also begriffe
definieren wie weiß sorgte ist es geht
um was wie ein gefühl oder sowas wie
wahrnehmung also man sieht was zu tun
ist und man tut es man will es auch tun
weil habe ich das gelingt weil man den
wichtigen ethos hat richtige charakter
oder gewohnheit hat und wenn man weiß
was ja das wird nicht wirklich
interessiert und jetzt kommen wir jetzt
zu dogs zu der frage was das alles mit
der politik zu tun hat was ihn wirklich
interessiert ist wie mit nicht so sehr
können wir aus buchstabieren was die
tugenden sendung was zu tun jetzt in
jeder situation wie ich gesagt habe das
ist alles zu ungenau und verschieden das
kann man nicht sagen aber was man schon
sagen kann es wie produzieren wir
menschen die in der lage sind das zu tun
vernunft einzusetzen um die sehr
richtige mit identifizieren
das machen wir durch erziehung wir es
sie einen menschen das machen wir wenn
wir kinder erzielen wollt vorwiegend
junge menschen wir erst ziehen menschen
damit sie die gewohnheit haben immer
diese mitte zu erstreben oder
auszusuchen
zum beispiel dass ken beim hessen wenn
es kennen zu wenig ist schwimmfähig das
kind wenn das kind zu viel isst schimpfe
ich das kind kämpfen kämpfen kämpfen
kämpfen das ist wahrscheinlich die
griechische art kennt er zu erzielen
natürlich schmerzt nicht nicht jetzt
aber damals also aber irgendwie erzielte
scannt dass das kind gewohnt erst
richtig zu essen und der ist nicht nur
beim essen sondern in allen bereichen
der handlung zum beispiel erzielt das
kennt kann
tapfer im krieg so seien dadurch dass
das kennt vielleicht spielchen mit den
freunden markt mit schwer mit
holzschwert oder sowas
das wäre typisch harz halt liche kinder
zu erziehen damit sie später tapfer sind
oder wir führen sie in das politische
leben ein
sie sehen wie andere leute mit
politischen fragen umgehen
sie erwerben dieses gefühl für richtige
handlung und dann wenn sie dran sind
selbst entscheidungen zu machen
treffen sie die richtige entscheidungen
und letzter punkt was auch nächste woche
spar wichtig sein wird weil man die weil
man gewöhnt ist die richtige
entscheidung und richtige handlung zu
wählen
also richtig vernunft einzusetzen in
jeder situation genießt man das auch und
man hat lust daran richtig zu handeln
oder vielleicht könnte man eher sagen
dass es schon dass meine schmerzhaften
würde falls zu handeln zum beispiel ich
genieße mein abendessen nichts wenn ich
zu wenig esse aber auch nicht wenn ich
zu viel ist das macht mir keinen spaß
also was mir bequem ist ist die richtige
menge zu essen oder selbst im krieg also
es klingt ein bisschen komisch zu sagen
dass der tapfer der mensch krieg genießt
oder kämpfen genießt aber es würde ihm
mehr wehtun wegzulaufen als zu stellen
weil er tapfer ist und da da sieht man
schon dass lust ein bisschen
rehabilitiert wird also lust ist nicht
das ziel aber kommt
mit der tugend ist so irgendwie damit
verbunden
und vielleicht werde auch also erde ist
netz und wir wollen erde war das ein
zeichen dass wir die tugend ausgewählt
haben aber tugend ist das ist zentral in
den besten leben weil die tugend die ein
resultat ist der richtige einsetzung der
vernunft im praktischen leben
das ist seine dass es eigene seine
ethische theorie kurze zusammenfassung
das war es für heute jetzt werde ich
diese fragebogen verteilt und würde sie
tragen